We will finish our discussion
of classical statistical
methods by discussing a general
method for estimation,
the so-called maximum
likelihood method.
If an unknown parameter can be
expressed as an expectation,
we have seen that there's a
natural way of estimating it.
But what if this is
not the case?
Suppose there's no apparent way
of interpreting theta as
an expectation.
So we need to do
something else.
So rather than using this
approach, we will use a
different approach, which
is the following.
We will find a value of theta
that makes the data that we
have seen most likely.
That is, we will find the value
of theta under which the
probability of obtaining
the particular x
that we have seen--
that probability is as
large as possible.
And that value of theta is going
to be our estimate, the
maximum likelihood estimate.
Here, I wrote a PMF.
That's what you would
do if X was a
discrete random variable.
But the same procedure, of
course, applies when X is a
continuous random variable.
And more generally, this
procedure also applies when X
is a vector of observations and
when theta is a vector of
parameters.
But what does this
method really do?
It is instructive to compare
maximum likelihood estimation
to a Bayesian approach.
In a Bayesian setting, what we
do is, we find the posterior
distribution of the unknown
parameter, which is now
treated as a random variable.
And then we look for the most
likely value of theta.
We look at this distribution
and try to find its peak.
So we want to maximize this
quantity over theta.
The denominator does not
involve any thetas.
So we ignore it.
And suppose now that
we use a prior for
theta, which is flat.
Suppose that this prior is
constant over the range of
possible values of theta.
In that case, what we need to
do is to just take this
expression and to maximize
it over all thetas.
And this looks very similar to
what is happening here, where
we take this expression and
maximize it over all thetas.
So operationally, maximum
likelihood estimation is the
same as Bayesian estimation, in
which we find the peak of
the posterior for the special
case where we're using
constant or a flat prior.
But despite this similarity,
the two methods are
philosophically very
different.
In the Bayesian setting, you're
asking the question,
what is the most likely
value of theta?
Whereas in the maximum
likelihood setting, you're
asking, what is the value
of theta that makes
my data most likely?
Or what is the value of theta
under which my data are the
least surprising?
So the interpretation of the
two methods is quite
different, even though
the mechanics
can be fairly similar.
The maximum likelihood method
has some remarkable properties
that we would like
now to discuss.
But first, one comment--
we need to take the probability
of the observed
data given theta.
This is a function of theta,
and maximize it over theta.
In some problems, we can find
closed form solutions for the
optimal value of theta, which
is going to be our estimate
but more often, and especially
for large problems, one has to
do this maximization
in a numerical way.
This is possible these days,
and routinely, people solve
very high dimensional problems
with lots of data and lots of
parameters using the maximum
likelihood methodology.
The maximum likelihood
methodology is very popular
because it has a very sound
theoretical basis.
I will list a few facts, which
we will not attempt to prove
or even justify.
But they're useful to know
as general background.
Suppose that we have n pieces of
data that are drawn from a
model from a certain
structure.
Then under mild assumptions,
the maximum likelihood
estimator has the property
that it is consistent.
That is, as we draw more and
more data, our estimate is
going to converge to the true
value of the parameter.
In addition, we know
quite a bit more.
Asymptotically, the maximum
likelihood estimator behaves
like a normal random variable.
That is, after we normalize,
subtract the target and divide
by its standard deviation, it
approaches a standard normal
distribution.
So in this sense, it behaves the
same way that the sample
mean behaves.
Notice that this expression
here involves the standard
error of the maximum likelihood
estimator.
This is an important quantity.
And for this reason, people
have developed either
analytical or simulation methods
for calculating or
approximating this
standard error.
Once you have an estimate or
an approximation of the
standard error in your hands,
you can further use it to
construct confidence
intervals.
Using the asymptotic normality,
then we can
construct a confidence interval
in exactly the same
way as we did for the case of
the sample mean estimator.
And this, for example, would be
a 95% confidence interval.
Finally, one last important
property is that the maximum
likelihood estimator is what
is called an asymptotically
efficient estimator.
That is, it is the best possible
estimator in the
sense that it achieves the
smallest possible variance.
So all of these are very
strong properties.
And this is the reason why
maximum likelihood estimation
is the most common approach for
problems that do not have
any particular special
structure that
you can exploit otherwise.